[Music]
bye foreign
live from santa monica beach the 2002
ifp west
independent spirit awards
he's forgotten more about sexual
deviance and fashion crimes than most
people will ever know for the second
year in a row here's your host
john water
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you and welcome to the 17th annual
ifp west independent spirit awards
the awards show that seems to believe
david lynch is too commercial this year
where where a feel-good movie about a
child molester with a hard-on of gold
wins the most nominations
an award show that celebrates what will
come in sixth at the oscars
and to top it off you have me a mentally
ill host who wishes someone would streak
him tonight
a host that encourages winners
long-winded political speeches about
causes we've never heard of
so viewers can laugh derisively at the
self-importance of show business
blowhards
we've had a tough year independent film
struggled at the box office
do you know some nights in some theaters
not even one person comes to see our
films when they're playing
you think i'm kidding but i'm not check
the local details of your box office
reports it's no misprint
a lonely monday at the 10 p.m show
somewhere in mid-america
every seat is empty you've done the
press junket
you've gained all that weight for the
role you've worked for scale
to prove how serious you are about your
craft and still
not one single person cares
no one came and the theater employees
are actually happy
they get to go home early with full pay
even when times are bad we're still
lucky though to be in show business
suppose the unspeakable happened and
suddenly you were a normal person
a civilian as they say out here in
hollywood
stars remember the few times you weren't
recognized in a store and how shabbily
you were treated
this is normal life for most americans
no celebrity no power no free food and
worse yet no gift bags
suppose you had to spend your own money
[Music]
imagine being invited to a party and you
have to bring the host to present
instead of the other way around
and two-week paid vacations like most
people
you've got to be kidding hollywood's
closed for a month at christmas and
everybody's jewish
now at least the paparazzi would leave
you alone but but then you'd realize
the only photos taken of you would be at
family get-togethers
and these pictures wouldn't be retouched
being recognized can be humbling even in
the most best of times you know a flight
attendant on a plane recently
was fussing over me giving me that
celebrity treatment and just before the
flight landed she leaned over and
whispered into my ear
you are ed wood aren't you
she wasn't kidding i
i advise you all to have backup careers
just in case
i do i have a vaudeville act i i just
played a perverted priest in blood feast
2.
and if i if i had to i could be a
teacher in jail again
some days i miss jail actually
i guess even big time directors are
technically eligible for unemployment
but it's a little embarrassing if you're
recognizable
and besides they might get you a real
job what could any of us do
if we couldn't make movies directors are
always telling people what to do in
films but in the workplace we might get
punched in the mouth
where would control freaks like us get
work at a walmart as a supervisor
studio heads would make good welfare
workers green lighting food stamps and
emergency vouchers but
somehow power without fame can sometimes
be so pitiful
think think
think of your worst moment in show
business the morning your film opens and
every review that comes through the fax
machine trashes your performance
remember that first day on the set as a
director when you called action and the
entire crew gave you the finger
distributors that awful phone call from
the big theater chain advising you that
your picture was yanked off every screen
after the first matinee due to hostile
audience reaction
and what agent can forget his top client
odin at the premiere
embrace your failures blow up all your
negative reviews and post them outside
your home
brag that your film has been rejected by
every major international film festival
publicized the fact that your movie
broke the record for the lowest per
screen average
find out all the names of the 105 people
that saw your film nationally and send
each and every one of them a thank you
note
now if you want to leave this business
forever go insane and have some real fun
you know
second ads alter the call sheets behind
the bossy ads back and get him or her
fired
dps light those divas from below give
them double chins and bags that even
botax can't disguise
accountants actually pay people net
point profits
publicis if you're handling a star that
gets on your nerve swag the bastard
that's what i hear this
revenge is called at the end of your
hellish press day
the press agent rushes back into the
hotel suite just after the star leaves
empties the minibar steals the liquor
breaks some furniture
stains the sheets with chocolates and
gets out quickly
the studio will fume at the hotel's
padded bill the gossip about the star's
alcoholism will begin
his or her sex life will be besmirched
by the maids and the offending quote
talent unquote will never be the wiser
movie stars if you really want to burn
some bridges right after principal
photography has been completed on your
highbrow project
immediately star in the porno knockoff
version
head big and his big ten inches up in my
deep end
in the bedroom nude things in my son's
behind
and l.i.e down
if if you change your mind you can
always make a comeback if one of your
old films is playing in a revival house
do what an actor of mine did
since he played the man with a singing
sphincter muscle in pink flamingos
nobody much remembered his face
but he'd sit in the audience and when
his part came on the screen he'd tap the
person next to him and say
that's me imagine the horror
the word of mouth what better way to
announce you're back
if if you've always been typecast switch
your image if dolly parton would get out
of drag take off her makeup and play an
alcoholic she'd win every award there is
surprise the public space i could
get exaggerated collagen lips
steve buscemi be 210 for a year
cameron mitchell marry a woman
you know what maybe it's time for normal
people to pull a switch on us and start
acting like celebrities themselves
viewers do it tomorrow give attitude be
privileged become a star for just one
day
hand out call sheets to your families
that morning
scheduling every second of their day
with chores to make you look better
pretend the pta meeting or the rotary
club is your premiere
charge an expensive outfit at your
department store and return it the next
day with makeup stains and get your
money back
have a neighbor drive you in their beat
up car and sit in the back seat and wave
to startled passers-by
demand your partner walk three steps
behind you and as you enter remind him
or her that you use the casting couch
carry a cheap tape recorder pick your
favorite soundtrack queue and blare the
music every time you make a point in
conversation
when friends rush out to greet you tell
them you'd prefer it if they didn't make
eye contact
steal a pocketbook and pretend you
thought it was a gift bag
if anybody criticizes your behavior as
boorish sniff that you've always been
quote review proof
and then just laugh at how ridiculous
celebrity can be
we all need to laugh at ourselves if we
can think of the most embarrassing day
we've ever had in show business and
chuckle
will be the strongest survivors of all
proud to be between pictures
proud to be outside the system and
honored to be a part
of independent film thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
now before we present our first award
let's hear it for a guy who's done more
mixing than ben affleck at the after
hours party in la dome
from the documentary scratch mix master
mike
and now to present our first award
please welcome jillian anderson and eric
stultz
supporting mail
hi we're here to present the award for
the best supporting
male 1 male 1 actor
oh um i know everybody's anxious to find
out who the first winner is so let's get
to it
the nominees for best supporting male
actor are
steve buscemi for ghost world
i can't believe they having like the
opening half and not that quick
insult you know there's gonna be lots of
girls for you to put from at this bar
i'm not holding my breath in that
[Music]
what are we in department motion here
come on what are you hypnotized that's
the more kids why don't you
[Applause]
[Music]
don cheadle things behind the sun
at least i got a face now to put one of
the that screwed up her life
and you not only screwed up her life and
my life
but you screwed up her kids lives too
man
the kids she ain't never gonna have
because that rape left her sterile
did you know that mr professional snoop
yeah yeah oh you knew that yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
billy k l i e
who was your little girlfriend howie
blitzer
where does he live randolph drive look i
i didn't know he took the gun still
afterwards
and i yelled at him and but he already
sold him
you're not going to hurt him ryan would
i hurt a boy
i'm capable of it yeah get in the car
[Music]
garrett morris for jackpot i will give
you
any synopsis any kenny rogers i'll even
throw in delilah okay
just give my man sonny george jones
grand tour
it's my song lis i know what you're
saying baby you sing that song just like
you wrote it hey man everybody knows
that
but tonight i want to be for my man
sonny let that be the deal
okay john c
reilly the anniversary party
and having lived with an actress now for
six years i'm sure you'll find directing
them a piece of cake
[Laughter]
so god bless both of you guys
and hopefully claire and i will be
a shining example to you for many years
to come
god bless
and the spirit award for best supporting
male
actor goes to steve buscemi for
ghostwriter
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much um
i think i will take john's advice and
i'll try and get a tan
and uh reconsider that offer i got for
goat world
um i'd like to thank terry zwagoff for
uh his wonderful direction
and uh i'd like to thank he and dan
claus for the incredible script that
they wrote and
uh for holding out for me to uh
play the part um i'd like to thank the
mr mud group leon halfon russell smith
john malkovich i'd like to thank the
wonderful cast
thor birch thank you so much scarlett
johansson
stacy travis and and and the whole cast
i'd like to thank universal ua
for the support of of the film uh
chris mcgurk bingham ray and everybody
there
and thank you all so much i really
appreciate this
it's really an honor thank you so much
from ghost world and a beautiful mind
please welcome scarlett johansson
and adam goldberg
[Applause]
first screenplay
okay so uh we're here to present the
award for best first screenplay
yeah what is it no no it's fine nothing
is kind of a load of crap isn't it i
mean that's for a screenplay like these
guys don't have a desk drawer full of
like unproduced uh spec scripts
i mean certainly just like because this
one was produced suddenly it's their
best first one
i had a philly cheesesteak sandwich you
know my first one when i was 18. i don't
go around clowning my best first you
know
chili philly cheesesteak sandwiches you
know it was good it was great
yeah but i had ones before him no it
went straight to your ass too
really yeah i think i have a hot ass
yeah you have really nice i think it's
spelt
um anyway so um enough for spontaneous
woody banter
um whatever uh the nominees for
best first screenplay are daniel claus
and terry zwygoff for ghostworld
richard kelly donnie darko
jennifer jason lee and ellen coming the
anniversary party
john cameron mitchell hedwig and the
angry inch
steven m ryder michael questa and gerald
cuesta for l.i.e
and spirit award goes to daniel claus
and terry's wagon for ghostworld
[Applause]
[Music]
um i guess first of all i'd like to
thank that lousy rat bastard terry
zweigar for making me come up here by
myself
when he knows i have a terrible social
anxiety disorder
um i'm sure i'm sure terry would join me
in thanking uh
everyone involved with with making the
film the cast and crew and
and especially our beloved producer
leanne halfon who
who took uh please
we took two uh two unseemly louts a an
aging documentary uh filmmaker and an
obscure cartoonist and turned us
into big shot screenwriters
and thank you for not laughing
um and of course uh
the the crew and and the cast especially
uh
my two girls scarlett and and thora
and the great steve buscemi
and uh and the the the generous
patronage of united artists and granada
film
and and lastly to my beloved wife erica
for not hating me after all these years
thank you
[Music]
please welcome the star of such
independent classics as a woman under
the influence and wings of desire peter
falk
[Applause]
john cassavetes award
i found my wife
i adore sweetie i'm here to
present the john cassavetes award
[Applause]
this award used to be called best movie
for five hundred thousand dollars
but this year they decided to rename it
after one of the few
truly original forces
in the history of movies the father
the father of american independent
filmmaking john cassavetes
uh well it says up there i'm honored
uh
i'm also very happy to be here because
john was a dear friend
and uh perhaps you people don't know but
some of his best films
faces a woman under the influence
was made for five hundred thousand
dollars actually faces was made for far
less
so there would simply be
no american independent cinema as we
know it today
without john's work
[Applause]
[Music]
john was the first and john was the best
take it from me and john
paved the way and john set standards
that all of us in this room are trying
to live up to
so the nominees for the first annual
john cassavetes award
are acts of worship
writer director rosemary rodriguez
producers nadia leonelli
frederick sunwall and rosemary rodriguez
if you need help i will help you
i'm gonna be sick
you want to run your bed
please don't leave me alone
jackpot director michael polish
writer producers mark polish and michael
polish
tonight lord give them the strength to
judge my man son with complete
honesty amen amen all right ladies and
gentlemen please welcome
sunny holiday
[Music]
step right come on
in if you'd like
to take the grand tour
of the lonely house
that once was home
[Applause]
[Music]
falls writer directors producers
josh apter and peter olsen
sure you're not going to need this yeah
i'm sure i don't need it
that was a 300 phone
well i guess we're done cutting the meat
right you probably won't be needing this
anymore will you
[Music]
punks director writer patrick ian polk
producers patrick e and poke
tracy e edmonds and michael mccoran
what are you doing for dinner tonight um
maybe you could join us oh thanks for
the offer but i have to cook dinner here
you know when you move into a place
where the first time you have to cook
dinner then
freeze up the evil spirits and all i
mean it's all wives tale
sounds so supernatural well maybe we
could join you
you shouldn't have to fight off all
those demon spirits all by your lungs
well yeah really you and your
significant other one of you left or not
i mean that's just me but really
perfect what time should we arrive
[Music]
virgil bliss director writer joe maggio
producers joe maggio and john maggio
i know who i am
and running away ain't gonna change
nothing
people change not me
you're just scared yeah maybe i am
what about your kid what about him
don't don't you want to see him again of
course i want to see him again
we'll go down to miami i'm kidding that
is the first place he'd look
how do you figure that because devo is
the one that sent him there in the first
place oh right
and the john costimati spirit award goes
to
[Applause]
[Music]
jackpot
[Applause]
[Music]
once was
i have nothing here to say
just something that i will tell
you some things
thanks we want to thank um number 49
the table over there
i don't think we'll be able to check
this on the planet
um i don't think anybody really is
associates spirit award more than john
cassavetes
and um it's nice to be mentioning this
in the breath with cassavetes even
any guy named john would probably do
thank you
thank you very much thanks sony thanks
john cry garrett morris
[Music]
if the independent film community were
the mafia she would be the dawn
please welcome ifp west's executive
director don
hudson
[Music]
hi everybody it's amazing to be in this
tent with the people who have made a
difference in american cinema
without you we would have only the
entertainment industry
wretched predictable spineless and
driven by one goal
return on investment but with you we
have
american movies with heart and vision
and spirit you are that small committed
group of people
who have changed the world all 1300 of
you in this tent
incredibly talented and passionate
people are here today
and i'm just going to name a few like
writer directors curtis hansen
allison anders and the genius david
lynch
actors like sir ian mckellen
ellen burstin stockard channing
and naomi watts risk-taking producers
like ted hope and james sheamus and
christine vashon exhibitors like greg
lemley and bert manzari
who go out on a limb time and again for
unknown filmmakers
and all the committed distributors who
are here today
who have raised the ceiling on what an
independent film can be
and a small tenacious community who
write about independent films
thank you for championing the little
guys over and over again
thank you also to the companies who are
bold enough to align themselves with a
band of outsiders
supporting all the independent
filmmakers in this room and many thanks
to our new principal sponsors
starbucks coffee company and to audi of
america
especially mary maria nahagian and
marianne wilson
and thanks to our old friends from
turning leaf coastal reserve vineyards
lupus galas and brian mcfadden and our
premier sponsors from directv
susan collins and stephanie campbell and
from express
ed razik michael weiss and our dear
marian schwendemann who's watching us
from home
and from motorola the fabulous david
pinsky
from entertainment weekly john squires
and dave morris
and from the bravo and independent film
channel three people who have given
their hearts and
souls to independent film ed carroll
jonathan serring
and kathleen dorr
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks also to our honorary co-chairs
the awesomely talented nicole kidman and
the master filmmaker hang lee
[Music]
and thanks to our spirit award producer
for the eighth year diana dianazon story
as all of you know ifp west has services
all year round for independent
filmmakers
and one of our most important programs
is the los angeles film festival
this is our second year and we move the
dates to june 21st through june 29th
and most important we have a new target
filmmaker award
which comes with a fifty thousand dollar
cash prize
that's fifty thousand dollars cash
american for the winning filmmaker at
the festival
it used to be that you could walk into a
movie theater and come out changed
you'd seen something that altered the
way you see the world and today that's a
lot harder to come by
today more often than not you come out
of the theater
knowing that you've just paid for the
advertising campaign for a theme park
ride
but for the rest of us for those who
would rather be
nourished who would rather be
challenged who would rather be truly
entertained
come to the festival come join ifp
because all of us working together can
do what no one of us
however talented can do alone thank you
[Applause]
next up thank you
next up is a man whom i adored in moulin
rouge
and in everything else he's done on
stage and film please welcome john
[Applause]
what's up leguizamo films rule let me
tell you
i'm so proud to be here i've done a lot
of independent films that gross
less than my shoe size but i got a
chance to try
crazy characters and other things i
would never been allowed to
try and experiment with so i'm proud
here to introduce
headwick and the angry inch the first
nominee for best feature tonight
and we're going to keep showing some
clips in between just because i know you
have a short attention span for this
award
and hedwig and the angry i mean where do
i start i mean
it's it's not your average german
transsexual glam rock
love story musical not really
and i know what john cameron mitchell
went through you know i did wong fu
and i know the joys of peeling duct tape
from your nutsack at the end of a long
shooting day
dps yelling at you hey hey get back to
the wardrobe john
you're showing package
that's what happens am i right john or
what
it's right there how can i miss that
coat right
hey hey close those legs man
hedwig is a great example of how
something massive can come from
something very very small
so to speak
they started the show in a drag club
they moved it
from a lower manhattan club to a big hit
off-broadway then they turned this
big hit into an even better movie that's
why hedwig tears down
boundaries that you know bound all of us
she reinvents the rock musical and she
looks right in the tube top
ladies and gentlemen hedwig and the
angry inch follow
my voice
[Music]
so
rock stars
how many times do i have to tell you you
don't
put a bra in a dryer it
[Music]
wops
please welcome two spirit award veterans
from the business of strangers
and the rookie stockard channing and
dennis quaid
we are honored to present the motorola
producers award
a tradition here at iop west recognizes
an up and coming producer
and offers him or her an unrestricted
grant of 20 thousand dollars funded by
motorola
now people sometimes wonder what does an
independent film producer do
well an independent film producer has to
show a level of commitment unsurpassed
by almost anyone in the industry
for example you know that guy on la
cienega dressed up like a submarine
sandwich waving at cars he's actually
independent producer
he's just trying to get his film off the
ground lauren spinder right
yeah yeah uh now
actually he's on he's on fairfax but um
anyway
um the motorola producer's award honors
just that spirit
of dedication and the nominees are
renee bastian and linda moran producers
of martin and orlov
and l.i.e
adrian gruben producer of treasure
island and olympia
jasmine kosovich producer of just one
time and the adventures of sebastian
cole
nigelia nelly producer of perfume and
acts of worship
and the motorola producers award goes to
renee bastian and linda moran
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa so i wish some of the people up
here had been a little bit more
less eloquent i'm thinking desperately
of something clever
to say and i nothing comes to mind uh
thank you so much afp west for
recognizing our work in such a fashion
this is really
uh very very important to us um
what we would like to say is that when
you make films
in the way we have done so far with very
limited resources you can only do that
through the contribution and help and
great work of a lot of other people
and and we would like to receive this
very sexual
thing uh
on behalf of the many uh very very
talented directors and performers and
crew people that have
worked with us and enable us to do the
kind of work that we have done and it's
great for us to see so many of them here
in this room nominated
today some of them that should have been
nominated have not been nominated
and romeo toronto is here the dp you did
a great work in lie and and and
pfelt is a composer who uh did great
work also on the same movie
and uh just very briefly before i let
linda say some things i would just like
to uh
thanks fendi and my future wife for
hanging in with me and also not hating
me after six years
bearing with me in this industry thank
you very much
thank you
[Music]
we particularly want to thank our our
fellow producer and wonderful director
on l.i.e michael cuesta
thank you the great actor brian cox
we brought such humanity to this role
and such credibility to our film and
the fearless jeff lipsky and everyone at
lot47 thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome the spirit award
nominated writer director of the
anniversary party and the star of
six feet under alan and rachel
griffiths
we're here to present the award for best
screenplay but first
we wanted to take a moment to talk about
an issue that affects all of us
we can all debate the merits of studio
films versus independent film but
one thing is for certain that far more
people get laid after watching a studio
film
we feel that this has gone on long
enough
and to give you a sense of the crisis at
hand we had the ifp west research staff
put together a little graph
this graph represents the percentage of
people who got laid after a typical
saturday night screening of the mummy
an impressive 82 percent
and here are the same numbers for donnie
darko
18 clayton leopold
91 lae
11 charlie's angels
100 in the bedroom
independent filmmakers we beseech you
would it kill you to make a fish out of
water romantic comedy
or a sexy suspense thriller with a
shocking surprise ending
we're confident that if more people got
laid after seeing independent films
they'd return time and time again to see
more independent films
and get laid thank you
and now the nominees for best screenplay
are
milo attica and will rockers for
monsters ball
[Music]
henry bean the believer
rob fessinger and todd field for in the
bedroom
richard linklater waking life
and christopher nolan for momento
and the spirit awards the best
screenplay goes to
christopher nolan for momento
[Music]
[Applause]
there's
[Music]
thank you very much um this is a
tremendous honor
very grateful to
everybody ifp thank you very much um
i the screenplay would just be sitting
in a drawer somewhere if not for
an enormous number of people in fact it
wouldn't even be in a draw at all if not
for my
brother jonah who came up with the story
that it's based on thank you jonah
[Music]
then i'd also like to thank my wife and
producer emma thomas
[Music]
aaron ryder at new market will tower
chris fools at newmarket and everybody
else there
team todd jenna suzanne thank you very
much
patrick walks burger at summit and the
great bob burney for distributing the
film thank you
and a whole number of people who
contributed to the making of the film in
incredible ways
my wonderful dp wally fister
my great production designer patty
podesta and
my incredible editor dodie dawn
[Applause]
and not least of all an incredible cast
carrion moss who's here today as well
thank you very much
the extraordinary joey pants and
perhaps most of all guy pierce who gave
an incredible performance
um thank you
she won a spirit award for her debut in
girl fight and is currently starring in
resident evil he
starred and you can count on me please
welcome michelle rodriguez and mark
ruffalo
debut performance
so uh it's difficult to describe the
prep
it's difficult to describe the pressure
that comes with acting in one's first
major role in the film
even on the most supportive sets you
get the feeling someone is holding their
breath hoping that you don't
screw up
the only way to get through it is to
focus on the basics
know what the character wants and when
you talk tell the truth
and when you're not talking listen
the actors in this category succeeded in
giving voice to a group of
unforgettable characters
the nominees for best debut performance
are
paul franklin dano
in l.i.e sorry about bringing that bimbo
[Applause]
did you ever think for a second how i'd
feel about that
i mean you were just like well mommying
around so i'll just get someone else
but that decision took you like a week
i mean how would you feel if i got some
guy to replace you
absolutely father how we time's uplift
i guess i'll see you when you get
yourself out of this mess
honor reader acts of worship
don't talk to me like you know me
because you don't know me yes i do alex
i know you better than you know yourself
oh you think you're better than me no i
don't think i'm better than you i've
changed and you haven't yet
i have changed and you haven't yet jesus
do you know what digna
i am not you and i don't want to be you
dumb girl
clint jordan virgil bliss it seems that
there are
several inaccuracies here on your
application yeah i was going to
tell you about that was when virgil well
you know when you saw what a good worker
you're an excellent worker it's just no
i mean have you seen them bathrooms in
there how do you my lunch often
bathrooms in there
nobody's saying you're not a good worker
it's just that we have certain policies
virgil i i wish you two what if i worked
a couple extra days
huh i mean you don't even have to pay me
i come in for free for a couple what
about weekends i work weekends if you
want me to
yolanda ross stranger inside
jumping it down what are you talking
about
you see i'm trying to tell you something
here i've been waiting a long time for
this
my whole damn life i've been waiting to
find you and they telling me i'm crazy
for liking it in here but trying to get
over here next to you
you see all that this is all i know
you know what i'm saying
i'm up in this mother because of you my
flesh and blood
[Music]
hillary howard anthony leslie and
mitchell riggs in caterskill falls
you seem to be very uh big on this whole
planning thing
which you know well i'd rather be kind
of different there
i don't know there's a big part of me
that wishes we could just be a little
bit more
spontaneous and kind of live
whatever we wanted to live and not
necessarily make all these plans i think
we can plan and be spontaneous honey
i don't think it's a question of
spontaneity i think
i think it's a question of thinking
through
your behavior
[Applause]
it's time and the winner is
[Music]
paul franklin daniel l.i.e
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
wow all right first of all
i brought michael quest up here the
director of l.i.e because uh
i have to thank him for everything uh
yeah he uh he gave me the opportunity to
play this part
and uh he also you know he gave me
everything verbally and everything in
the script which
he co-wrote which i had to do and i i
really couldn't have done it without him
so
that michael quest and i just can't
thank him enough all right i'd like to
uh
also just thank uh stephen gerald who
co-wrote the script with michael renee
and linda our producers brian cox uh
glucose starting with me and uh he was
such an amazing help
there's some tough stuff we had to do in
there and you know he helped with my
confidence and
my motivation everything i can't thank
him enough romeo
tyrone judy henderson jeff lipsky
everybody at live 47 thank you very much
um and i'd like to thank my family for
putting up with me
and my manager sandra chang industry
entertainment acme and uh
i guess i'd just like to thank all these
people for helping me achieve
one of the greatest accomplishments of
my life this far which is really
this film and this award just goes to
show that so thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome a woman who never met an
independent film she didn't like she's
the star of the upcoming feature pumpkin
christina ricci
best feature best feature
l.i.e is not your average love story
the film explores the relationship
between a charismatic ex-marine with a
history of preying on young boys
and a 15-year-old boy who is desperate
for guidance and affection
the relationship between howie played by
paul franklin dano
and big john played by played by brian
cox
strikes a balance between offending our
sensibilities and forcing us to
reconsider
our notions of paternal love it is a
film that inspires
questions challenges and enrages
and is one you won't soon forget here's
l.i.e
[Music]
demon or bird said the boy's soul
is it indeed towards your mate that you
sing
or is it really to me for i that was a
child
my tongue's used sleeping now i've heard
you
now in a moment i know what i am for
die awake nevermore the cries of
unsatisfied love be absent from me
never again leave me be the peaceful
child i was before
singing songs
[Applause]
[Music]
the beast is back please welcome sir ben
kingsley
without without
supporting actors every film would be
swimming to cambodia
and uh yeah and even
spalding grey gets very very lonely
so not to take anything away from solo
performers but one must admit that it's
very nice to see
actors interacting with each other on
the screen particularly in independent
film
where the supporting roles tend to be
more interesting
richer than the lead roles in most
studio films
and our nominees for best supporting
female
are davina mcfadden
stranger inside
smell it
[Music]
nothing like the smell of freshness
fresh from california
yo granny used to grow kale and tomatoes
remember that little garden she had on
the uh on the balcony
was never around girl i was always on
the street and in trouble
those are your memories mine aren't the
same at all
harry and moss momento
i'm not taking your classes huh it's
hard for me to
so you have information for me is that
what your little note says
yeah must be tough living your life
according to a couple of scraps of paper
you mix your laundry list with your
grocery list and you'll end up eating
your underwear for breakfast
i guess that's why you have those freaky
tattoos
summer phoenix the
jewish believers the only people that
ever talk about it that much are jews
nazis talk about it all the time do they
real ones hitler and gerbils they talked
about it incessantly
is that why you became a nazi to talk
about jews incessantly
you want to punch in the mouth okay
tamara tooney the caveman's valentine
i get together all right about these
people
you better open your eyes take a look
around leave me alone woman
how'd you get in here anyway i rode in
on your dreams
well right on out
you better wake up baby before you get
murdered in your sleep
you hear me you better wake up
uma thurman tape
i hope you die for it and go to hell and
if there is no hell
i hope you suffer on your way to death
my hope is that your last living
sensation be that of a steel rod
being shoved repeatedly up your insides
so that it batters your heart
and punctures your stomach
that along the lines of what you wanted
and the spirit award for best supporting
female
goes to carrie and moss
[Applause]
[Music]
there's
thank you so much i always get so
emotional when i talk
so ignore me um
it always happens um i feel so honored
to be an actor and to make a living at
being an actor it's such a blessing
and um i thank you christopher nolan for
giving me the opportunity to play
natalie
it was really so much fun for me and i
thank you
and newmarket i thank you as well and
team todd thank you so much
um uh guy pierce
what an amazing performance he had in
this film
i thank him joey pants you know i love
you
wherever you are i'd like to thank my
team of
elizabeth hodgson my manager of 11 years
my agent scott lambert hildequiely
bob lang my lawyer my publicist jennifer
allen
i hope i'm not forgetting anybody i have
such amazing friends who support me to
uh
you know live in the moment and face
fears maria bello you're a big one for
me
and um my mom who's in vancouver
had to find the cable station to be able
to watch this in canada thank you mom
[Laughter]
and of course my my love of my life my
husband stephen roy thank you so much i
love you more than anything
and thank you this is huge for me and i
thank you
very much thanks
[Music]
well i'm back because there's something
else cinematically alarming i feel
compelled to
share with you we're here today to honor
movies but if we're really honest we'll
admit most people end up seeing our work
on video or dvd
these days small towns sometimes only
have one movie theater left and i
guarantee you
lumumba ain't gonna be playing
so they'll see our movies on tape which
is okay without video
my early filthy films could have never
infected such a motley group of young
male contents
a few kids in the stick still remember
me as their first bad influence and i
can only thank the video business
but dvds are even better leave it to
hollywood to figure out a way to get
people to buy the same film three times
laser vhs and now dvds the technology
that inspired the collector gene
in all movie lovers dvds are now the new
hardback books
if you go home with somebody the first
thing you do is snoop through their dvd
collection
to see if you'll sleep with them people
with bad titles don't get lucky
and video only not even a good night
kiss
dvd buyers today seem to demand bonus
footage well suppose you don't have any
left over from your film
do you have to do reshoots to supply
fake outtakes
buy edited lifts that were cut out of
other people's movies with the same
stars and they pretend they're yours
hire lookalikes to shoot blooper reels
and why is it the directors are the only
commentaries on most dvds
isn't it getting a little cliched why
not use the editor's voice
can't this hack of a director match a
shot you should have seen the footage i
had to work with i saved this film
how about the craft service people we
never get to hear from them
imagine what they'd say to hell with
food issues that and allergic to
salt i put some in her lunch yesterday
she didn't die did she
eat what you're served in great
now since the dvd release is getting so
important to a film's eventual long-term
reputation
isn't it time to make in-store signings
more glamorous i sign everything the
fans bring
birth certificates school detention
slips parole cards
even a colostomy bag is it pulsated on a
customer hey
he paid his 29.95 for the dvd who am i
to judge really
now i have a problem with porn on dvd
you can't fast forward properly it jumps
ahead missing detail
you all know what i mean um but but the
porno business sure knows how to promote
and maybe we ought to pay attention take
porn stud jeff striker's example
after appearing totally nude on stage in
his play he would stand naked and fully
aroused at the exit doors
while ticket buyers followed by and had
their picture taken with them
now i call that showmanship
hollywood stars could really do the same
thing if you appeared semi-nude in your
film couldn't you at least appear
semi-nude in the video shop
come on some of you are semi nude here
today
face it our business is based on
voyeurism even in your best reviewed
motion picture
someone in the audience is imagining you
naked so show it
show it raw in this business you've got
to be an exhibitionist
to survive thank you
thank you
[Music]
please welcome the producer and star of
the upcoming film the man from elysian
fields and the star
of just like mona andy garcia and diane
lane
[Applause]
cinema cinematography
we're here to present the award for best
cinematography
cinematographers in independent film
today work in an increasing
variety of mediums from 16 millimeter to
high definition video
but whatever their medium choice their
job remains the same
make it look as good as you can for as
little as you can
tonight's nominees have overcome
limitations of budget
and time to create a stunning visual
world
the nominees for best cinematography are
frank g demarco hedwig and the angry
[Applause]
inches
peter deming mulholland driver
[Music]
iii the american astronaut
giles nudges the deep end
[Applause]
wally fister momento
[Music]
[Applause]
and the spirit award for best
cinematography goes to
peter deming
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much i'd like to thank
members of the ifp
for uh this is cool
like to thank abc for rejecting us
and starting all this
thanks to studio canal elon starred
pierre alderman for breathing new life
into mulholland drive
after his dead for a year and a half
universal focus for finishing the job so
well
um collaborators mary sweeney michael
player
neil edelstein jack fisk
thank you very much to very talented and
patient cast
laura elena herring justin thoreau naomi
watts
to my crew because so much of what ends
up on the screen is their hard work
and they never really get to stand here
at podiums like this
and to to writer director david lynch
for being
for being an increasingly singular voice
in the world of
independent film for being absolutely
fearless in the laboratory
for trusting us to bring his dreams and
visions to the screen which is no easy
task
and to be a pleasure and a privilege to
work with let's do it again
thanks
please welcome two of mexico's rising
talents on the stars of e to mama
tambien diego luna and gael garcia
[Applause]
bernard
film hello hello
we're here to present the award for best
foreign film
they gave us this category for a very
complicated set of reasons that they're
not open for discussion
but but now
now we have cash credit card
and a united states visa okay
here's where you elvis well
and the nominees are emily director john
pierce
[Applause]
[Music]
amores perros director alejandro
gonzalez
[Music]
[Applause]
sexy beast director jonathan glaser
[Music]
together director lucas madison
[Applause]
and the spirit award for
okay best foreign film
it's four
[Applause]
because now we know the public america
the american audience
m boku le film european aveda suited
love
european movies with subtitles
so
jean brass twos who pretty thank you
very much
[Applause]
backwards or forwards there's only one
joey pantaliano
[Music]
how are you hey listen andy garcia and
diane lane we just announced the new
stars of just like mona
which is my screenplay that i'm
directing we don't have financing yet so
i'm at table 46. um
you know memento is a every independent
filmmaker's worst nightmare and i want
to say that
two years ago today the night before
friday night everybody saw memento
and all of these studio guys were coming
up to me saying oh my god memento's such
a great movie i said you're going to buy
it no
nobody wanted to buy it and i said why
and they said well you know it goes
backwards who want to
nobody the movie's not going to make a
nickel joey but uh
you were good in it
[Applause]
uh everybody knows the story behind this
movie is christopher nolan i did it
he did a great job and uh based on his
brother jonah's uh short story
and i'm really proud to be a part of
this movie and it looks like
a few people have won so far so it's
even better
it's a movie that goes backward and i
never got the story point to the matrix
so what the hell am i talking about
i just want to say that all you
filmmakers out there keep up the good
work work hard
and all you guys with money you studio
executives tattoo
make good movies on your chest and every
once in a while look down at it
here's the memento tape
i have to believe in a world outside my
mind
i have to believe that my actions still
have meaning even if i can't remember
them
i have to believe that when my eyes are
closed the world's still there
do i believe the world's still there
is it still out there
we all need mirrors to remind ourselves
who we are lenny
i guess i've already told you about my
condition oh well only every time i see
you
when you find this guy what are you
gonna do i'm gonna kill him
do not trust her she's gonna use you to
protect herself
teddy don't believe his lies you wander
around
playing detective well maybe you should
start investigating yourself
i want my life back
she starred in sidewalks of new york
he's nominated tonight for things behind
the sun
please welcome heather graham and don
cheadle
[Applause]
we're here to present the someone to
watch award which
spotlights an innovative new director
and comes with an unrestricted grant of
twenty thousand dollars
in the past the sponsors were all
watchmakers hence the title someone to
watch
yeah the title summoned the watch it
worked on so many different levels you
know
not only were the sponsors watchmakers
but the winner also was awarded
a watch so you know and someone is also
a play on words because
someone you know someone won
so it's someone
but this year we're proud to welcome a
new sponsor turning leaf coastal reserve
the makers of the fine wine that you're
drinking today
however this uh this presents a rather
interesting dilemma
because you know people kind of got used
to the whole someone
watch thing and when the watchmakers
pulled out they kind of screwed us
so so we toyed with other names like
someone to drink
um someone to leave
someone to reserve someone to whine
somebody tossed that out but it didn't
seem right to win an award and then call
it someone to whine
so yeah
so in the interest of simplicity and
with much gratitude to the people at
turning leaf we're going to lead the
title as it is for now someone to watch
and now the nominees for the turning
leaf coastal reserve someone to watch
award
are deborah eisenstadt director of
daydream believer
kari streeter and demayne davis
directors of lyft
michael gillio director of quick stop
david mcquilling director of too much
sleep
and the summon to watch award goes to
deborah eisenstein
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
um thank you so much ifp west for this
and for the sponsors of this award i'd
also like to thank
quickly my husband my family everyone
involved
who supported this project
sybil kempson jennifer jackson michael
pilgrim the slam dance film festival and
steven beer and my sister jill most of
all
thank you
[Applause]
here to present our next award is the
man who has voted this year's show
west's male star of tomorrow
ian mckellen
[Music]
uh hello wonderful to be back
here and this is a very special day for
me
because i just had my first facial
and my first uh manicure
and my first pedicure
because i wanted to look my best for
these five wonderful actors so the
nominees for best male lead
are brian cox for
l.i.e
[Music]
she's so proud of you told me all about
your poetry too
you know i had something published in
england if you like i show it to you
you want a diet yeah you like your cops
huh
well if you finish this i'll uh i'll
give you a right back to randolph drive
okay i'm going that way all right that'd
be great
[Applause]
[Music]
ryan gosling for the believer
in the near three centuries it's taken
these people to emerge from the ghettos
of europe
they've ripped us out of a world of
order and reason they've thrown us into
a chaos of class
warfare irrational urges relativity
into a world where now the very
existence of matter and meaning is in
question
why because it's the deepest impulse of
a jewish soul
to pull at the very fabric of life till
there's nothing left but a thread
they want nothing but nothingness
nothingness without end
[Music]
jack gyllenhaal for donnie darko
stop eating twinkies and maybe go out
for field hockey
you know what no one ever knows what
they want to be when they grow up
you know it takes a little little while
to find that out right jim
and you yeah you
you think of some jerk shoving your head
down the toilet way you know what
maybe you should lift some weights or uh
take a karate lesson and the next time
he tries to do it you kick him in the
balls
[Music]
john cameron mitchell for hedwig and the
angry
all the people i have come upon my
problems i have to think about
the people who have come upon me
tommy can you hear me
from this milkless tit
you sucked a very business
we called show
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
and tom wilkinson for in the bedroom
you are that's what he said
and you're pulling the same with me
and that's a horrible way to be it's
horrible
you're a bitter ruth
and you can point your finger at me all
you like but you better take a damn good
look at yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
and the spirit award for best
male lead goes to tom wilkinson for in
the battle
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much it's wonderful uh
uh anything that happens tomorrow now is
going to be an anti-climax
just on a personal uh
note i was very nice to to be bracketed
in this award with the wonderful actor
brian cox whom
whom i've
i'm in a certain way sad to say that
i've known for
way over 30 years but uh it's
it's nice to see him today i it's very
easy to do your job
when you're surrounded by actors like
celia west and bill wise
will your may father nick stahl marissa
to may and
spacek and it's very easy when
you're directed by our brilliant
young visionary todd field
and it's also easy to do your job when
you have the support of a wonderful
family
diana hardcastle my wife and our two
wonderful children
alice and molly and
finally i just if you ever ever had
notions as independent filmmakers of
being
so the poor relations or whatever it is
you might feel
ian and i are british and um every film
we make is an independent film
so and we're happy with that but thank
you very much and i'm very glad
please welcome the stars of the miramax
film stolen summer
bonnie hunt and kevin
[Music]
[Applause]
documentary please be seated thank you
that was kind of neat mckellen oh
mcclellan
he looked good after all that yes very
nice did you see the lord of the rings
he was great
no i didn't see him this isn't written
down by the way we're just vamping this
now
you didn't see it really better be good
kevin no i didn't see it
i really liked it see i hadn't read the
lord of the rings book so i didn't know
what to expect
i didn't hadn't read the books plus a
few years ago i saw lord of the dance
and that sucked so i didn't really know
i'm sorry i'm flustered i was making out
with joey pants backstage
that was written down
we actually wrote some stuff for us to
say about project green light the
documentary series
well reality tv show yeah yeah how many
folks saw it
just so we know
[Music]
okay as an actor or actress if you get
asked to participate in one of these
race away find
a place to be and go there and hide
anyway we are here to present the award
for best documentary
and we will give that award to a
talented individual that is upholding
the tradition of filmmaking that we're
so proud to be a part of
and the nominees are
dog town and z boys director
stacy peralta
[Applause]
go tiger director kenneth a carlson
[Music]
the legacy of cotton director susan from
deborah dickinson and albert maisel
promises directors justin shapiro bz
goldberg
and carlo bolado
[Music]
scratch director doug pray
and the spirit award for best
documentary goes
to dogtown and z boys
[Music]
[Applause]
is
first of all we'd like to all welcome
you to our parking lot
because uh 30 years ago this guy right
here
up here this is our neighborhood this is
where we grew up
and our film is about about eight losers
who grew up as surf rats on this beach
skateboarding on this parking lot right
here
and we never knew 30 years later that
anyone would recognize us for
infecting the world with skateboarding
six in the morning offshore winds
radioactive
outlet we surf here we live here we love
you
welcome to our neighborhood i want to
thank some people for our parking lot
welcome to our parking lot really quick
i want to thank my producer aggie orsi
who's heart and soul in this project
we could not have done this without her
editor paul crowder who's heart and soul
in this project also made the biggest
hugest most
difference thanks to sony classics for
believing in us thanks to alliance
atlantis
thanks to deborah mcculloch mark ryder
for putting together the dream
soundtrack and thank you
independent spirit awards for allowing
people like us in this building
thank you very much and april and glenn
friedman
fans tennis shoes thank you for
supporting us
[Applause]
50 bucks you can buy a pair of my shoes
we're not michael jordan we don't
we're not gilded we're ghetto straight
out
and you all are ghetto too now because
you're here partying
please welcome a man who was independent
before independent was cool
dennis
[Applause]
[Music]
best hopper best feature
in allison anders most personal film
things behind the sun she explores the
countless unseen repercussions of
rape in a single act of sexual brutality
perpetrated against two childhood
friends
leaves their lives in pieces now that
they're adults
they still live in the shadow of
violence behind the sun
with this film anders gives the voice to
the unspeakable
here is things behind the sun
would it make you feel any better to
know that the guy that raped you
is in prison yeah
it sure would maybe rotten hill too i am
happy to report he is
imprisoned i mean
who are you talking about
[Music]
this sweet little girl who never
had the chance not just for the record
more than one guy right no no but dan
dan
dan was the one
do you remember this what is real
you don't even know her man you don't
even know her
[Music]
he's a hulking presence in independent
film and this year's honorary co-chair
please welcome ang lee
best director thank you thank you
uh i'm an honor to be here tonight to
present the wolf of best director
now at other award shows the the
category 2 is given to the person
who has done the best job as director
but here at these spirit awards this
category is for
people who are not capable of doing job
any job good or bad and
for the independent directors this is
not really someone
you want to hire for anything he or she
is
sorry nothing screw me up
sorry about that
for the independent director it's not
really someone you want to hire for
anything
he or she is driven haunted by the
images
and ideas even if polite on the surface
is rude and mounted
maniacal on the inside and also boring
because they are incapable of thinking
or doing anything except
that which will help them to make the
movie that is inside of them
each of the today's nominees in this
category is
i'm sure unemployable and inhuman in
their own particular way
and that's worthy of all our respect and
of course our fear
[Music]
the nominees for best director are
michael guesta
l.i.e
inside
ritual link later awaken lie
john cameron mitchell for hedwig and
angry inch
christmas nolan for memento
and the work goes to
christopher nolan for momento
[Music]
um well if you're lucky enough to get
nominated for more than one award
um and you're lucky enough to win one
you tend to put all your eggs into that
basket
so i don't actually have another speech
prepared but
um so i'll just once again say thank you
very much to
ifp and uh everybody involved in the
making of the film who i've already
named
um and just to thank the the one set of
people that i didn't
in the last speech which is the
audiences for these films
um i think our film perhaps more than
any other
uh benefited from people's willingness
to
see something a little different from
what everybody else was offering and uh
i think that uh everybody would do well
to have a lot of faith in
audiences because certainly in our case
they came to see our film and i'm very
grateful to them
so thank you
[Applause]
please welcome the stars of mulholland
drive and the upcoming feature full
frontal naomi watts and blair underwood
[Applause]
first feature
directing your first film is perhaps the
purest expression of your talent
and also possibly the most difficult you
channel all your passion
personal experience and creativity into
one single expression of everything you
believe in
only to get that faithful call saying
congratulations you've just done a small
film that's interesting small
and interesting now let me hire you to
do something that's neither
but for now tonight's nominees can take
pride in the fact that their first film
was made
on their own terms yes the nominees for
best first feature
are the anniversary party directors
jennifer jason lee and alan i
love you
trust that please don't do this
artist come here come on good boy come
on
i'm not sure we understand that word in
the same way oh no
what love you walked out of a
five-year-old that's not the first thing
to do with love sally is about
whether we can live together like this
all the time it's not like this all the
time do i want anyone else
no do i want to be with you for the rest
of my natural life
i am really trying
[Music]
the believer director henry bean what
did you do
outside of this killing your son what
could he have done
what could he have done sergeant's
killing his kid
what could he have done he could have
jumped the guy gouged his eyes out
grabbed his bayonet they would have shot
him on the spot they would have been
dead in two
seconds who are you to just so he's dead
big deal he's worse than dead now he's a
piece of
that's it you're going back what do you
think he should have done danny don't
listen to him it's all a bunch of crap
what's crap the so-called holocaust
it never happened
[Applause]
[Music]
donnie darko director richard kelly
another friend real or imaginary
would you like to talk about this friend
frank
frank what did frank say
he said follow him follow him where in
the future
and then what happens and then he said
then he said that the world is coming to
an end
do you think the world is coming to an
end
no
[Music]
ghost world director terry zweiger
didn't you be training about upsizing
yeah
but i feel really weird it's pretty
sleazy
it's not optional
jesus hi
uh can i get a medium seven up medium
yes sir do you not know that for a mere
25 cents more you could purchase a large
beverage
and you know i'm only telling you this
because we're such good friends
medium is really only for suckers who
don't know the concept of value
[Music]
and in the bedroom director todd field
i want to know what's going on
oh you're obviously upset
is there something we can talk about
talk who us what if somebody walked in
they wouldn't recognize us they think
they were in the wrong house
do you want to talk or not oh you mean
about our dead son
no we haven't before
why should we bother now
[Applause]
[Music]
and the spirit award for best first
feature goes to
in the bedroom todd field
[Applause]
[Music]
um this is for
a best first feature and as um
i'm sure many people in this room
realize
when you are attempting to make your
first feature film
it's like trying to climb mount everest
with about three pickup trucks on your
back
[Music]
and you need so much help
in so many ways and
i was truly truly blessed in the people
that
i was able to collaborate with on this
picture
beginning with graham leader and rob
festinger
um andre debusse who wrote the short
story that
the film is based upon and then
ted hope um ted
ted hope and ann carey at good machine
were the first people to read the script
and said we're going to make this
one way or the other we're going to make
it and
along with with ted and anne
[Music]
ross katz the indie fatigable amazing
ross cats
refused to to let the the film die and
it was a very very hard film to get
made as you could see from the get laid
graph it's a
not terribly sexy film um even though
the title is
in the bedroom um
i i was also blessed in in having a
tremendous amount of
uh uh support and
really actors
celia weston bill wise justin ashford
william maypother nick stahl
marissa tomei spacek tom wilkinson
these are very very smart actors they're
and i would have had to really have been
a an
idiot to to screw it up i i really just
stayed out of their way and that's
that's the truth um i also would like to
mention
some people that that that rarely get
mentioned
but i would like to acknowledge my
cinematographer antonio cavace
my editor frank reynolds my costume
designer melissa economy
my production designer who is uh
shannon hart spacex serena bathbun
my wife who
came kicking and screaming but really
really saved us
and i know i'm leaving
about a billion people out but thank you
very much
[Applause]
please welcome one of the stars of
waking life and tape ethan
[Applause]
hawk
uh can you hear me is it working
yeah uh it's my honor to be here tonight
to present waking life i've had the
pleasure of working with richard
linkletter
uh four times and for over the last 10
years i think he's really embodied
what the independent spirit really is um
thank you um he's carried on a a long
tradition
of i screwed up the whole thing uh but
yeah okay a great tradition of films
about people sitting around talking
talking about things and ideas that make
life beautiful
as well as unfathomably strange waking
life is a rambling series of
speculations on everything from the
purpose of
collective memory to the relevance of
free will it shows us that the search
for meaning is its own reward uh
combining richard's filmmaking with
brilliant animation of bob
savaston the film creates an entirely
new cinematic consciousness
and here it is waking life
what do you think of my little vessel
she's what we call seaworthy
s-e-e see with your eyes i feel like my
transport should be an extension of my
personality
voila and this this is like my little
window to the world
and every minute's a different show
[Music]
you often feel like you're observing
your life from the perspective of an old
woman about to die
remember that yeah i still feel that way
sometimes
like i'm looking back on my life like my
waking life is her memories
the ongoing wow is happening
right now we are all co-authors of this
dancing exuberance
where even our inabilities are having
roasts we are the authors of ourselves
co-authoring a gigantic dostoyevsky
novel starring clowns
welcome the president of ifp west's
board of directors and the star of the
upcoming film hoffman
bondi curtis hall and lily sobiewski
a documentary starts with nothing but a
feeling a feeling that an audience might
be interested in some obscure segment of
society
or a bizarre cultural phenomenon that
feeling sparks curiosity
that curiosity grows into obsession
singular determination that will not
rest until the story is told
it is those obsessed view that the the
directv
ifc truer than fiction award was created
to honor
this award is accompanied by a twenty
thousand dollar unrestricted grant
funded by directv and the independent
film channel ah
the finalists for the 2002 directv ifc
truth and fiction award r
udette beselberg for children
[Music]
[Applause]
underground
[Music]
[Applause]
goldberg carlos bellato and justine
shapiro for promises
[Applause]
[Music]
alex lambert for the mark of kane
monty mccollum for hybrid
[Music]
and the directv ifc truth and fiction
award goes to
monty mccullen for hybrid
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much it really means a lot
to me um
i couldn't believe that a film about an
old farmer and corn could go so far
and i really want to thank my wife who
edited the film and
made so much possible that was there
[Applause]
[Music]
as well as my my family who who stuck
stuck through it and
persevered through my relentless
interviews
um and the festivals that believed in
the film
and and this uh directv
award i just um
sitting in my hand here but just thanks
thanks a lot
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome last year's spirit award
winner for requiem for a dream who can
be seen this summer in the divine
secrets of the yahya sisterhood ellen
[Music]
hi bursting well they say that hollywood
isn't writing great parts for women
anymore
but after acting in requiem for a dream
last year
and seeing these nominees i think the
best roles for women are found in the
world of independent film
[Applause]
the nominees for best female lead are
kim dickens for things behind the sun
you know what matter of fact i don't
want to drink and i don't want dinner i
don't want anything
i just want to get out of here because
you're starting to piss me off because
you think you know more about my rape
than i do
maybe i do
do you want to know about my rape you
think you know
try this on try living your life knowing
that all your sexual desires have been
colonized
by your rapists try living with the
guilt knowing that the only way you get
turned on
is by acting out the very thing that
ruined your life try living with that
one
molly parker
molly parker for the center of the world
we did it that was real
no but you didn't feel anything what do
you expect
i mean you hired me yeah but a lot of
stuff has happened since then nothing's
happened no
it's all in your head what about
yesterday what did you think that i was
falling in love with you
i love you you don't even know me
spacing for in the bedroom
or if you go through anything
but that's your choice dear not mine
good time writers my choice is not to
scream at the world one
maybe one of us has to be reasonable
around here you ever think of that
reasonable team matt
i don't know about you but i miss my son
i'm glad you have time for reason so
what you imparted to frank that
sense of reason
tilda swinton for the deep end
perhaps your righteous despair perhaps i
could be trying a little harder
maybe sometime tomorrow between dropping
dillon at baseball practice and
picking up my father-in-law from the
hospital
i might find a way to try a little
harder
maybe i should take a page from your
book
go to the track find a card game
maybe i should blackmail someone
[Music]
[Applause]
and carrie washington for lyft
that's what you think you didn't even
tell him you left
you left and it's my fault
pew he was gonna leave me how do you
know that
you don't and either way you still had
me my man's gone now too
angelo's dead
am i standing here blaming you for that
[Applause]
and the spirit award for best female
lead
goes to spacex
[Music]
[Applause]
oh for heaven's sakes who cares how big
your trailer is anyway
or even if you have one i want to thank
our wonderful producers though
by the second day they provided us with
the most wonderful honey wagon
i thank you
i want to thank our wonderful my
wonderful cast mates
especially tom wilkinson
my my my roots are deep in independent
film i've
i've worked in independent films for
since 1973 so
this picture was really like coming home
and i want to say that i think
todd field really embodies
all that a independent filmmaker
needs to embody and that is a tenacious
character a little bit like a bulldog
i want to say one thing for all
independent filmmakers to remember
it's not the size of the dog in the
fight
but the size of the fight in the dog
thank you
[Applause]
she's the star of moulin rouge and this
year's honorary co-chair he's the star
of pinero
please welcome nicole kidman and
benjamin brax
[Applause]
best how are teacher hello nicole
you feel good yeah it's a big weekend
for you now
yeah break a leg or whatever they say
thank you
go get him no it's great though to be
here because um to be asked
it was such an honour to be asked to do
this i have such admiration for people
that go out
and um fight for what they believe in so
here we go so what we will announce
next will probably change the course of
the rest of the afternoon for many of
you
right yeah well let's get to it
the nominees for best feature are
hedwig and the angry inch producers
christine deshawn
peter ramel and pamela copper
[Music]
[Applause]
l.i.e producers renee bastian linda
moran and michael cuesta
momento producers jennifer todd and
suzanne todd
things behind the sun producers daniel
haser doug mankoff
and robin alpa
[Applause]
and waking life producers ann walker
mcbay
tommy pallada palmer west and jonah
smith
and the spirit award for best feature
goes to
i'm shaking memento
produced by jennifer tron and suzanne
[Applause]
todd
there's nothing we have to say
[Applause]
[Music]
is
thank you uh thank you to the ifp for
this and um
my sister suzanne and i are so proud to
produce this film
and we're proud to represent it for the
many people who work so hard to bring it
to you
and it is truly an independent film
it was independently financed and
independently distributed
and the force behind this was a company
called new market capital
especially will tire and chris ball
is our group over here i also want to
thank bob burney
who led the distribution i saw earlier
i want to thank patrick waxberger and
summit entertainment as well
oh i'm so nervous i want to thank my
crew who's here tonight our dp wally
fister
um patty podesto our production designer
our academy award nominated editor dodie
dorn
our our and our line producer elaine
deisinger
i want to thank our amazing cast um the
lovely carrian
our good luck charm joey pants who
reminds you that he is the good luck
charm every chance he gets
and uh and of course the amazing guy
pierce and uh
the other filmmakers i need to thank are
clearly uh jonah nolan
who not only wrote the script though
this the story the script was based on
but he also worked
as a pa on the film and he said
appreciate me for mentioning that
i want to thank our our associate
producer emma thomas nolan who worked
very very hard on this
i want to thank aaron ryder who is the
unsung hero and engine behind
the movie our executive producer
and um last but not least we want to
thank of course chris nolan who is as
nice to work with as he is talented and
it was
a joy to watch him put this movie
together and a joy for us
and uh i think for everyone in the cast
and crew and as you already heard
tonight this was
an independent movie that we made we
showed to distributors and
nobody wanted as joey told you for jen
and i you know we've made a lot of
studio films and this was our first
independent film so you can imagine
what that evening was like the film we
were so proud of that nobody wanted to
distribute
so obviously the audience finding it
meant so much to us and working with the
talent like christopher nolan is just
a once in a lifetime experience and i
have to say to everyone at home who
loves movies the way jen and i have
since we were little that you should
follow your dreams and follow your
passions and you know like jen and i you
can be two little girls sisters from the
valley and
you know make some of your dreams come
[Applause]
true
[Music]
[Applause]
well that's it everybody thank you for
coming go out this weekend and pay to
see
uh nc 17 or an unrated movie thank you
very much
[Music]
wicked
hey
quick quick
[Music]
is